[Music]
tonight on brian ross investigates
kidnapped and held for ransom america
got tough with kidnappers after the
Lindbergh baby was kidnapped in the
1930s now there are new victims American
hospitals schools government agencies as
hackers takeover of computer systems and
lock up what's on them demanding ransom
to unlock them city's email system is
shut down cities in Florida have paid
hundreds of thousands of dollars to get
their data freed so if hospitals and
schools around the country insurance
will cover most of the in traceable 65
Bitcoin demanded equal to about six
hundred thousand dollars the city paid a
twenty five thousand dollar deductible
should government's give in to these
online criminals what will it take to
stop it plus the unexpected death of a
popular young baseball player Tyler
Skaggs mourned by his teammates for the
Los Angeles Angels but now it turns out
he died with two opioids in his blood
and his family claims someone working
for the Los Angeles Angels may have
helped him get the drugs and our
shoutout for the reporter who's breaking
big stories on Union corruption with an
FBI raid on the home of the president of
the UAW one of the country's most
powerful and influential labor leaders
one of the neighbors across the street
could see agents in the garage counting
what this neighbor described as wads of
cash from the law and crime Network
studios in New York City's Herald Square
this is Brian Ross investigates
and good evening and welcome tonight a
close look at a very 21st century kind
of crime wave kidnappers demanding and
getting huge ransoms not from taking
children or celebrities but from hacking
into the computers of schools hospitals
local state and federal governments
taking their files and data captive the
victims say they often have no choice if
they want to get their vital and
valuable data back medical files school
records government documents the
kidnapping of little child's a Lindbergh
jr. was a tragedy not only to Colonel
and mrs. Lindbergh but to the nation
America got tough with kidnappers after
the child of aviator Charles Lindbergh
was kidnapped in 1932 and this is
Burnett Richard Hoffman 35 whose arrest
as Lindbergh ransom collector in the
kidnapping has aroused America make an
example of the kidnappers and let the
punishment fit the crime
in this garage across the street from
the Hopman home 13750 dollars of the
ransom money shown here was found now
across America from small towns to big
cities modern-day kidnappers are taking
computer systems hostage and demanding
big ransoms to unlock them in Atlanta
the city was hit last year with what was
called the Sam Sam virus freezing the
courts Airport Wi-Fi online bill
payments footage from police dashboard
cameras it was extremely disruptive to
the city but this has happened to people
worldwide federal prosecutors have now
indicted two Iranians charging them with
the so-called Sam Sam virus attack we're
here to announce that federal grand jury
in New Jersey indicted two Iranian
citizens for a three year scheme that
involved hacking into computers of
hospitals municipalities public
institutions and businesses in the
United States and in other countries and
just this summer more than 20 small
towns in Texas got hit faced with paying
a ransom or potentially losing all of
their vital files and documents Britain
National Health Service was hit first
forcing hospitals to stop what they were
doing because they couldn't access
patient records and as of this morning
it's estimated there are some 200
thousand victims and 150 countries many
cities half fade Lake cities email
system is shut down lake city in Florida
reportedly put up four hundred sixty
thousand dollars Riviera Beach in
Florida reportedly paid some six hundred
thousand dollars to get its files free
the city finally acknowledges successful
hacking attempt that the city will
indeed pay ransom on insurance will
cover most of the untraceable 65 Bitcoin
demanded equal to about six hundred
thousand dollars the city paid a twenty
five thousand dollar deductible and a
report by W NBC TV in New York found
several New York school districts had
been targeted some paid some did not
well Natalie the first day of school
will now be held on Thursday we've
actually had multiple cyber attacks on
local school districts recently and in
some cases the hackers have even held
the school's data for ransom and we're
joined now by the mayor of Lake City
Florida Stephen Witte and by Rob connect
II the former director for cyber
security policy at the National Security
Council now a senior fellow at the
Council on Foreign Relations and
co-author of the new book about
cybercrime and cyber war the fifth
domain thank you both for joining us mr.
mayor let me start by asking you why did
you agree to pay the ransom well you
know it was a tough decision but based
on the information we had what we were
looking at one of the biggest things was
it was possible we never could have
recovered the information that was
locked up the insurance as y'all stated
earlier paid all of it for $10,000 we
paid $10,000 and her documents back now
yes
there wasn't any guarantee that we'd get
them but I felt like you know if they
didn't do it that time then they would
kind of prevent them from ever doing it
again because people wouldn't believe
them but it took there's several weeks
to get it all back and you trusted them
enough to send them that much money in
bitcoins well with a lot of advice an
insurance company really took the big
risk
all right well Rob Kentucky
we asked you from your point of view
should cities like Lake City Florida and
others do they pay the ransom I think I
think it's a really tough call I think
what cities like Lakeview are dealing
with is the fact that if they don't pay
the ransom they are going to lose this
information forever it's not going to be
recoverable and they're gonna have to
revert the paper files to requesting
data from their citizens so we can
really impact operations that said what
we've done by allowing ransoms to be
paid is essentially helped to arm our
adversary so that $460,000 part of it
probably went to buy Lamborghinis and
leather jackets but a good deal of it
probably went to up their capability so
the attacks are you to give them more
brazen and they're gonna get more
capable over time Rob got a question for
you from our control room from the
executive producer Rhonda Schwartz
Rhonda so these attacks are getting more
and more frequent there were over 20
towns in Texas just last month with the
same problem should it really be the job
of each individual small town to deal
with this on their own or something more
need to be done at a federal level I
think unfortunately what can be done to
address these kinds of threats is really
good IT and good IT security it's not
necessarily something that you can hope
cyber command the US military or the FBI
are going to be able to address these
adversaries know what they're doing
they're operating from criminals safe
havens around the world we have very
little hope that they will ever see the
inside of a US courtroom and so from
that from that perspective the the best
defense is really going to be defense
it's really going to be to make the
investments to secure your networks and
protect your citizens data they're what
let me ask you you paid the money what
makes you think they won't hit you again
and if they do
are you more prepared absolutely since
then we've made sure that we wasn't
susceptible to it and we have spent
probably almost as much as the ransom
are we
we'll end up spending that much and new
equipment and being prepared the next
time now I've learned that you know
layers and layers and layers and you
have any sense from the FBI they're
gonna track down who hit you and took
your money we certainly hope so we know
everybody's working it's something that
as a nation we gonna be seeing a lot
more of the smarter we get the ball are
they gonna advance and it's just gonna
be an ongoing thing for persons
personally
businesses hospitals everybody what do
you think would have happened if you had
not paid the ransom was it really that
vital to get those files and documents
back I believe it was because that was
pretty much everything we had it was all
the records for years and years our
history our operating information it was
and it was a decision I had to make
based on the citizens not me personally
what would I do if it'd have been me
firstly but what would I what's best for
the community Rob Kentucky let me ask
you how do they target cities like city
in Lake City Florida how do they decide
their targets well what they're really
looking for is a target that's going to
be able to pay a ransom but that is also
vulnerable to whatever tools they're
using so if they're able to get into the
systems we say a spear phishing email
targeted at a city worker if that worker
clicks on the email and gives them
access to a system from there they're
gonna move through the system and start
locking it up so it's really a question
of what is the target that is least
defended but most likely to be able to
pay a ransom to them in an amount that's
going to make it worth their while and
is it your sense of Rob that these are
individual criminal organizations or is
it nation state doing this well we've
seen the full gamut we've seen North
Korea carry a very sophisticated
ransomware attacks we've seen the
Russians carry out an attack not palea
that was under the guise of ransomware
they actually in the end didn't care
about
any kinds of ransoms but we've also seen
criminal groups that have grown
increasingly sophisticated and in some
cases it's really hard to tell the
difference between a criminal group and
a nation-state group in the case of Iran
you've got entities that are carrying
out both the work of government as well
as moonlighting and mayor Witt has your
popularity suffered with your voters and
your constituents in Lake City well I've
really had no negative comments you know
pretty much people understand where we
were at the choices were so I think I
think they agreed that it was the right
decision to make at the time and not and
the insurance company came up with the
money yes that surprised you that you're
covered for that kind of thing I'm
surprised by that yes sir that words but
so out of your pocket out of this town's
taxpayers it was just $10,000 to make it
yeah great well Rob can actually they're
making millions on this I take it from
towns like Lake City and others yeah
what we can say here is the right
decision for Lake City it was probably
the wrong decision for the nation
because that money is gonna go to what
is going to be even more sophisticated
attack so the next round may not be
small cities in Texas the next round may
be large cities federal departments
critical infrastructure so the next
ransomware attack when it decides to
take out Florida Power and Light for
instance that's really gonna hurt the
citizens of Lake City well thank you Rob
Kentucky very much and mayor win in
Florida thank you very much for joining
us coming up next the tragic death of a
young baseball player and autopsy shows
huge amounts of opioids and alcohol in
his system and now his family claims an
employee of the Los Angeles Angels may
have been involved does baseball have a
drug problem when we return
we turn now to the unexpected tragic
death of a popular baseball player a
pitcher on the Los Angeles Angels by the
name of Tyler Skaggs the circumstances
surrounding his death have now raised
some serious questions for Major League
Baseball even as his team and his fans
and his family mourned his death on the
morning of Monday July 1st the Angels
organization lost a member of its family
Tyler Skaggs tonight while the grieving
continues the angels and Mariners joined
fans across the nation and the baseball
community in remembering this special
young man Tyler's mom Debbie will be
tossing an honorary first pitch to
Tyler's teammate and good friend Andrew
Heaney
but now the Skaggs family and the team
are about to square off in a potential
legal battle an autopsy found Skaggs had
a mixture of oxycodone and fentanyl in
his system and that he choked on his own
vomit and his family is claiming it was
shocked to learn that the circumstances
may involve an employee of the Los
Angeles Angels Major League Baseball
told us today it is now investigating
and unable to comment further so to
learn more were joined by one of the
country's leading sports writers bill
Jenkins the Los Angeles Times bill
thanks for joining us from Los Angeles
by Skype so what's the latest on this
case latest pretty much is what you said
it was Brian the family has put out a
statement after the release of the
autopsy reports saying they were
surprised to mention to learn that there
might be the involvement of a nasals
employee they have so far not given any
evidence to support that assertion and
in the meantime you have investigations
for major league baseball family and
also from the police department in South
Lake Texas which is where Tyler died and
until you get the results of all those
investigations I don't think we know
we're dead it legally all baseball bill
does drug test on his players for
performance-enhancing drugs but not so
much for illness
drugs like cocaine or fentanyl or
opioids yeah in the minor leagues where
there is no Players Union Major League
Baseball does test for what they've
called drugs of abuse which include the
opioids in the major leagues the Union
and the owners agreed on a proposal that
was enacted it said four drugs of abuse
the priority should be treatment it
should not be punishment because these
are not things that are considered to
enhance the players performance so
number one you can't be tested for
opiate unless there's some reason and
probable cause you've been in a
treatment program something like that if
you do test positive you're generally
referred to counseling or treatment in
some way and your name is not publicly
released as it would be if you tested
positive for steroids as you know in the
background baseball has had issues with
cocaine and serious drug abuse back to
the 1985 case in Pittsburgh with so many
players name there and then recently the
pitcher for the Miami Marlins Jose
Fernandez in a fatal boat accident found
to have cocaine in his system do you
think baseball has a larger issue here
that we haven't heard much about it
that's being covered up I don't know
about it cover up it's hard to know if
you have a problem if you don't have the
data to back it up so I think will be
interesting as the sched investigation
unfolds is in the Skaggs family turn up
any evidence that proves the assertion
that the Angels might be involved and if
so is it one rogue employee is there
something beyond that and again is there
information that would support any idea
that maybe this does go beyond Tyler
Skaggs right now we just don't know and
were you surprised of the allegation
that a an employee not a player but an
employee might be involved a little bit
I mean you don't really want to say that
unless you have some reason to say it I
don't think once you've lawyer it up
your lawyer would encourage you to say
something unless you had some reason to
believe that but on the other hand again
the Skaggs family is not yet provided
the evidence so we'll have to wait well
bill shaken the Los Angeles Times thanks
so much much more to come on this
we appreciate it we'll stay in touch all
right right up next our shout out for
the reporter breaking big stories and
allegations of corruption involving one
of the country's most powerful union
leaders with reports the FBI found wads
of cash in his garage when we come back
and our shout out tonight for the
federal court reporter at the Detroit
News who for the last two years has been
breaking some very big stories about one
of this country's most significant labor
unions the United Auto Workers the UAW
Detroit is a union town and the annual
Labor Day Parade is a big event but the
news coverage this year was driven by
the revelation that the city's most
powerful union leader Gary Jones the
president of the United Auto Workers the
UAW is the subject of an FBI
investigation of alleged corruption a
story broken by Roberts now of the
Detroit News there were protesters union
workers protesting you know decrying the
corrupt reports of corruption that have
come out of federal court Gary Jones
marched for part of the parade declined
comment to reporters on the scene and
left before the parade was finished
Snell who covers the federal courts for
the Detroit News first started working
on the UAW corruption story some two
years ago there's a lot of outrage in
some circles the the the workers fear
that this is confirmation of what
they've suspected that some UAW leaders
might just be out for themselves and not
for the average blue-collar worker so
far nine people have been convicted the
latest this week in federal court in
Detroit the Union has sought to portray
the convictions as not that significant
I mean I think we're fairly well sourced
with you know people close to the
investigation and there hasn't been a
challenging of any of the facts what
what they have tried to focus reporters
on is that this is merely a few bad
apples who have been charged
urged and convicted and that this
doesn't represent a broader crisis for
the UAW but this past week Snell and his
colleagues Brianna novo and Ian
Thibodeaux broke the story that the
union president himself
Jones was part of the investigation with
exclusive coverage of an FBI raid on
Jones's home during the search the
investigators had left the garage door
open at Gary Jones home and one of the
neighbors across the street who was
watching this dramatic federal search
unfold grabbed his binoculars and could
see agents in the garage with the open
garage door counting what this neighbor
described as wads of cash really sort of
a dramatic description of what was
unfolding on the scene today federal
agents descended on the homes of some
top officials with one of the nation's
largest unions the raid on the home of
the UAW president was picked up by news
organizations across the country who had
pretty much ignored the story until now
today FBI Special Agents searching
inside the Canton Michigan home of UAW
president Gary Jones it's been somewhat
of a lonely beat once we broke the news
that the FBI and IRS and labor
department were you know investigating
and searching multiple locations around
the country the the coverage mushroomed
you know you started to see the
financial wires and pretty much every
major newspaper Wall Street Journal
start to weigh in and cover the
developments from last week the
allegations are reminiscent of the
blatant corruption at the Teamsters
Union something I covered in my early
days as an NBC News correspondent except
now there are a lot fewer reporters
assigned to cover such stories it's
tough in the newspaper industry with you
know fewer resources but thankfully my
editors have stayed committed to the
story for over two years so it's it's a
matter of you know what we're gonna
devote resources to and this is
like you said a union town it's a big
story in Detroit and we've been staying
on top of it for two years plus and
there's more to come you think for sure
definitely in a statement the UAW says
the union and as president Gary Jones
have always fully cooperated with the
government investigation and suggests
what it calls profit laden auto
companies stand to benefit from media
leaks false assumptions and political
grandstanding but from what we can see
none of that would apply to Rob Snell
and the Detroit News now that's our
program for tonight thanks so much for
joining us we'll see you back here again
and next week